the Washington Redskins controversy has
taken a big new turn this morning the US
Patent Office has canceled the trademark
on the team's name the Patent Office
says the Redskins name is disparaging of
Native Americans that's a direct quote
our Washington bureau chief Jonathan
Allen happens to be here in New York
City today John great to have you here
and on the phone we have Amy Trask the
former longtime CEO of the Oakland
Raiders she's now an analyst for CBS
sports and Mark usko Morgan Creek
Capital Management my co-host for the
hour still here Amy we have to begin
with you this is not the first time that
Native Americans want a victory against
the Redskins name however it given all
the controversy swirling around the team
and the owner Dan Snyder it does feel
important tell us what you think what is
a significant decision and it is a
significant moment the the government
has in essence said look word we agree
with the dictionary the dictionary
defines this word as a derogatory slur
we agree with that definition and we are
not going to protect the marks and logos
any longer what does that mean
practically speaking for a team like the
skins well a few things there are going
to be certain appellate rights and the
legal work has not been exhausted yet
I'm not a patent or trademark lawyer and
really can't speak to that but what it
means is when all the appellate rights
are exhausted the federal government
will no longer be affording its
protection to the marks and logos which
means initially that others can go out
and use those marks and logos for
commercial gain and the team and the
league will not be able to stop that you
may also see fans starting to drift away
from from choosing to identify with that
at some point you may see some drop off
in the sale of merchandise perhaps more
significantly because because some fans
will always want to buy that merchandise
you may see C corporations and
businesses starting to walk away from
wanting to identify with that now that
the US government has spoken and said
yep it's a disparaging floor John you
could make a living writing in
Washington
dan Snyder exclusively I could
definitely do that and you know
fortunately have other things to cover
at times it can be difficult interview
untold but I think Amy's dead on here
but what's really going on is a patent
trade office is putting economic
pressure on the washington football team
on Daniel Snyder and the NFL which can
then put more pressure on Daniel Snyder
to just drop this name there's an
appellate process that you go to the
federal courts that's happened before in
this particular type of case against the
team name so this is the beginning slank
important to point out the skins won
that appeal the last night that's right
um but look if you're Daniel Snyder at
some point you would think that this is
becoming untenable you've got 50 in a
new way thank you got 50 United States
senators that have sent you a letter you
know I've lived in Washington my whole
life I grew up as a fan of this team I
would say most of my socially conscious
friends in Washington I would like to
see the team name changed you look even
at the logo the logo is is a caricature
and so I think ultimately there's going
to be a lot of pressure on Dan Snyder to
change this you know I think Eric made a
good point earlier that's the other
character caricatures in teams are even
worse you know Cleveland Indians you
know some might argue the braves vs yeah
this seems pretty natural but but it is
that it's a controversial topic yeah and
I would say that I think the direction
we're moving in we're probably not going
to look for the lowest common
denominator and team names in the future
right what's the worst one that we can
measure this guy good point I think
he'll eventually have to change it but
it may be a while Dan Snyder's are
pretty stubborn CEO and he likes to run
his place at some point though men
irrespective of the the stubborn factor
you just noted at some point though the
league as a whole needs to and perhaps
we'll say enough well maybe you would
know what power does the league have to
do that let's just think for a moment
about about what just transpired with
the Clippers in Los Angeles right we we
know that the league had only certain
powers that it could exercise it
exercised them there's still no
resolution there what could the league
do in this case well I think that the
greatest power and the greatest strength
that the league will have
comes not from its legal rates but from
the pressure that those owners can exert
on other owners and let me tell you that
is significant significant pressure when
you're in that room and there are 32
owners if at some point 31 of them or
even 24 of them say this simply isn't
okay then Dan Snyder is going to have to
decide that legal rights notwithstanding
whether he wants to have an issue as
between him and the other owner so
here's the key question we know that
Adam Silver stepped in and by all
accounts did the right thing for the NBA
is Roger Goodell you know him is he
going to do that for the skins in the
NFL you know I I would have thought so I
still hope so I've been I don't know I
don't want to say surprise but the
league's position on this has been duly
noted that not only us but we not only
has the league stepped back and said
we're not going to get involved the
league has been affirmatively advancing
the same argument that the Washington
team has been advancing so you know I do
have confidence that the league has the
ability to do the right thing I do hope
it will do the right thing and remember
one other things from an economic
standpoint the league has a pretty nifty
tool in its arsenal which is they can
amortize if you will the expenses
associated with a name change overall
30km Amy I'm afraid we have to leave it
there great of you to join us on the
phone Amy Trask for mercy of the Oakland
Raiders Jonathan Allen are your chief
from washington and mark I have to thank
you it's such a quick one